how's it going bros my name is Pam bad
welcome to ex mortis 2 part 2 with
babies crying or laughing I don't even
know the story is apparently we wake up
with the house but we can't believe
we're trapped
there's some sort of evil forces keeping
us here or bloody peer Oh what [ __ ]
Quinn rayon or just not Italy ah [ __ ] I
just click the girl I didn't wanna I
just touch it I didn't want to
I am awake now what do you want from me
I'm just there for the period I swear
hey them do anything I didn't uh bloody
period on the wall told me to wake up
why why why would they know that all
right Oh a second always anything to
click here and I just stupid thought
they would though I only wait I think
you know I don't even know where to go
anymore let's go left
uh huh already been a little favor I
don't like this place very much shut up
cat no one likes
kitty let me out hold time I don't like
kitten meows all times you just be good
kidding shut up I've been in all these
places I don't understand it must be
[ __ ] plays I don't been to and but
where makes no [ __ ] sense belch make
go soon huh I don't know ok let's know I
been there many times buddy mention
haven't been there many time
let's go like again cuz there's the only
place I haven't been properly properly
properly
wake up super creepy it's this period
here it's like hey you get nothing
you get period [ __ ] that's all gay
that's all de
all year as his life right there as a
life lesson for your kids
you only get ass period all you get is
period that's a life life learning
message from Peter by I should write it
all you get is period paper alright we
need to continue all the way to the
darkness or door that doesn't tell me
where to go
hole is too dark and it sounds pretty
good doesn't it oh God Mildred been
through this I've been in all these
rooms before I'm I guess it means I'm
County [ __ ] stuck doesn't tell me
tell me man who's looking at me with a
weird face I'm giddy all right we are
all giddy for quite frankly I don't get
it it's your [ __ ] clock what do you
want from duty what you want to do two
o'clock it's your one o'clock what do
you want okay I'll just leave that would
be awesome just ah maybe now we can go
here yeah I forgot about this play there
we freakin penis go
right here we got the door sounds a lot
behind you well that's [ __ ] great an
axe please tell me we can pick it up I
have a plugging X now what [ __ ]
oh is [ __ ] the old F of climbing unit
but the ducting Luntz away from the
actual aisles I have a [ __ ] axe I'm
back haha my bad ladies how about Alan
three times that was awesome that was
just awesome all right [ __ ] I got a
[ __ ] axe I'm bringing for God
underground tunnels though no I don't
know I know it's know what why why why
do I have to go here okay let's take it
real easy aft all right
Oh little it off King Klondike off come
Falana pinky bonnet only dolla Duff I've
done by jump if tuft of the four and no
[ __ ] we gotta go forward okay
it's just gone it's what no what is this
place
ah I can't go forward again alright
that's okay
go up like job this [ __ ] head up
that's what you get Bo III didn't mean
to do it I swear he ran for me and I
just cling I didn't want to drop is that
out I just drank brown now bro no oh no
I don't I don't like that I don't like
that at all I don't know but my oh wow
they're symbols ah must be fists I know
I know
he just ran I just chopped the negs
yeah and I just cranked any time and why
how I found a key then it's dirty out
there yes Dardis sweet sweet there oh
man dirt isn't so good that key is just
wonderful I wish I got poof from the
left one first
I needed cane
okay so what do we got oh-oh-oh-oh
no surplus well right nude Hey yeah just
ran for me I swear then kill it become
Bahamas more trees now wow I didn't
throw the not some quality he talking
about me rebooting the solution Raleigh
what was what is Ray run for the fires
no snakes assembly not her alright I am
just gonna bad and do [ __ ] I just
clicked come on brah
run for the forest I'm out here browse
me all the boys I'm just gonna go I like
blood and period everywhere alright
let's get let's just go here yes
oh [ __ ] bro ah no you failed escape down
stab try again
okay yes yeah go go click like a
[ __ ] I'm just gonna click like a
[ __ ] penis ha ha I had to watch
bye bye bomb biast what if I guys okay
let's go a sneak and peek okay good good
sneaking a peek
alright yeah what is this what is this
god this is cricket I don't even care
anymore I just gonna go buy bombers why
was it a factory he doubted my faith oh
okay thanks point is Abhiyan died I'm
not even gonna bother reading that oh it
repeated itself because we woke up and
we went in and all um now
I like I don't even know anymore I think
you and fellow anymore
anyway that was ex mortis there's a
second one it's supposed to be even more
scary unless I can even see me I don't
know Mike and favorite this video for me
if you want them and I'll play it
smartest student in a couple days
I can't do this right away anyway that's
pretty much it
oh my god oh my god they killed Mika ya
bastard